let's see if we can pick up one or two
more calls here why don't we go to about
nine five four nine five four sounds
good you're taller from nine five four
what's your name and where are you
calling from
9:54 are you there I told you no now a
bad idea you were right pad nine five
four was it had trouble written all over
it
let's go to six one zero caller from 600
me David David hi hi hi hi hey is this
not by four or six one zero hold on a
second there's a six one zero
oh and is is 954 there as well that's
probably nine nine nine that's my next
genome okay got it
okay six one zero what's your name names
just going Dragonborn and I'm from a
Western University go Rance okay very
good what's your question
listen um I'm sure you know Dave Rubin
sargon of akkad right I'm going those
people yeah yeah so I was wondering if
you if you then - and Kyle Kaczynski can
have like a 2-1 to debate okay and it'd
be moderated by a do you know Pope the
Franco is yes I do yeah at him moderated
and we can use it as like a fundraiser
thing because a few years ago back in
2012 I think it was John Stewart held a
fundraiser for autism right it is a
nasty myself I think that'd be an
amazing thing to do you know get to
libertarian and to left-wing minds them
just to fade each other over you know
the controversial stuff and then you
know raise money for authors I think I'd
be a great cause
okay well listen I we would have to see
what the cause should be but I am
willing to entertain this idea a
two-on-two debate me and Kyle Kaczynski
or kolinsky as I know him well I'm bad
for not the educating you know better
than I know dave rubin and sargon of
akkad also known as Karl Benjamin I
would probably want to debate him as
Carl Benjamin I don't know that I would
want to debate him as Sargon but
moderated by Philip DeFranco I like the
idea I'll be fair though David I guess
himself as a classical I just I've had a
few issues with some of them and I
wanted to call out by two people I can
respect and I respect both you and Kyle
quite a lot well listen we will be
into wait for the phone to ring for that
I am ready for the phone to ring or the
email box to light up okay
you said Dragonborn is your your handle
yet Dragonborn just call me that
Dragonborn okay well I've got nothing
else to call you so I guess I have no
choice alright Dragonborn thank you so
much really appreciate it a very very
interesting suggestion and we will
research and explore all right that does
it for calls we will take cop calls
again but we've got a great rest of the
show coming up for you today